Now,
I just finished this other one and I'm working on that one.
And a lot of it has to do with social media and a lot of it has to do with the
impact that it has on young people.
You know,
people are not really designed for this and you might be able to handle it if
your 32 year old man or a 35 year old woman or whatever you are.
But if you're a 15 year old girl,
this might,
it might be overwhelming.
I mean,
and the angst and the anxiety and you know,
wanting to know,
saying about the depression,
you know,
they see if they're not at a party where their stuff's not getting liked,
that has an impact on them.
And ultimately I think the networks need to be helping educate people how to,
you know,
whether it's this info,
educate people how to research.
I did see that youtube is starting to do like a,
you've been on this for too long type thing.
Really?
Yeah.
Like get a life you fuck yeah.
They tell you that I want to build stuff like that.
That's really important.
Yeah.
Helping people get off.
I haven't,
I haven't seen that.
I haven't done enough time on youtube where the kicking me off.
I have,
it's easy.
You know,
I was uh,
I sent,
uh,
Eddie Bravo,
this thing from the Guardian about,
uh,
the upsurge and people that believe in the flat earth and all of it because of
youtube videos and that apparently now youtube is,
they want to censor those.
They want to,
uh,
they,
they feel like flat earth videos and uh,
I think another one,
check this,
check this if I'm wrong about this,
but I think they also want to lean on those anti-vaccination videos.
I think there's a concern with those.
I think they're worried about a bunch of different things along those lines.
You know,
like they feel like there's disinformation and outright lies to being spread.
How do we combat it?
We own this platform.
What do we do?
They feel like they have a responsibility.
I think there is responsibility.
Okay.
But what is the responsibility?
If there's a debate,
I think it's more to educate people how to research as opposed to saying this is
or is not true.
Right?
Because who's deciding that?
Well,
I believe the earth is round,
but,
uh,
um,
I also believe it's such a stupid conspiracy that you should have it.
You should be allowed and it should be something you should show your friends.
Like,
dude,
I need you to go look at this.
This has 37,000 thumbs up.
And they really believe that the fucking earth is flat.
They really believe there's an ice wall outside Antarctica.
They really believe that the sky doesn't move,
that it's that the,
you know,
that we're in some sort of a,
they think it's like projected images or something.
Like there's a bunch of like really,
really wacky theories.
Like I think those are okay.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
But I think freedom of information sort of transcends a lot of these little
debates.
So if there was more freedom of information,
so we actually knew everything.
The government,
yeah.
About all of the different conspiracies and black projects.
The black budget.
Yeah.
More information is going to give both sides the ability to understand what is
happening.
That's true.
The reality is that we don't know what's happening and there is lots of secret
stuff.